hello everyone and welcome to another
game from the 2019 FIBA World Cup this
is a game from the rapid section the two
classical game is between onigiri and
Jeffrey Xi'an have been drawn then the
three rapid games were drawn and this is
Game four of the rapid section so the
last game before the magic goes into the
blade section the five plus three so
really a really nice game I hope you
enjoy it let's check it out
so Gary with the white pieces opens with
Knight to f3 the ready opening is on the
board we have g6 and now
efore with Bishop to g7 and now d4 sort
of a modern opening sort of like white
played efore and black continued with g6
with d6 and the now Bishop to e3 Knight
to f6 and with Knight to c3 Giri
transposes into the main line of the
pista defense we have castles by Shion
and then out comes Queen to d2 are
always a nice idea you want to Castle
queenside go after this Bishop on g7
with Knight to c6 the the most played
move here is c6 and well there are a
couple of other and I said he is Knight
to g4 you could to go after the bishop
on e3 right away but Knight to c6 is a
much rarer move so d5 as black did not
play c6 at the kick away the night with
Knight back to be it and then now comes
in Bishop to h6 now that the d5 has been
played the knight can now be developed
via the d7 square and by pushing the
five white has a week and these two
squares so the knight can use those if
if needed with blush up to h6 going for
this straight and now c6 Gary already
had this position against young young
shift of Duda now in Dortmund in 2018
that game ended in a draw and there if I
was played but here we have c6 but by
young and an outburst of captures and g7
with kink a person g7 and here Gary
castles Queen side and here there is a
one game where a six was played but here
C captures on d5 is played and this is
now a new move already as of moved in
with each character son b5 by giri and
now
Bishop to g4 you don't want to allow
this nice to move for white to start an
attack on the kingside with something
like f3 g4 and and a nice spawn storm so
Bishop to e2 not allowing Bishop
captures to ruin White's pawn structure
Giri goes Bishop to e2 and now Knight B
to d7 just continuing development we
have rook h t1 and now rook the c8 and
here
night-night study for offering a trade
of the bishops with Bishop capture Sonny
to rook captures I need to enter now
just Knight to e5 and excellent square
for the knight but Geary immediately
pushes it back with f4 and now Knight to
c4 attacking the Queen we have Queen to
d3 attacking the the night here and here
we have Queen to b6 so already
threatening threatening mate on b2 and
you have to prevent this with b3
preventing mate and now Knight to a 3
and already here
Magnus cross had made a joke that
Aguirre will probably go for the
repetition here with something like a
knight a three and then king b2 and then
Knight c4 check King back to C one night
a3 kinking between IC 4 and so on but
Gary did no such thing
Geary instead captured on e7 a nice pawn
sacrifice by Shion
who gives up a pawn for a very nice
attack with Queen to b4 now putting
pressure on the night here and Gary
defends it also again here
Magnus made a little joke he said that
if white tries a night Stewie for to go
after that I am neither than f6 then a
black has a very nice winning idea which
I'm sure yeah you will see since the
night and the rook are attacking the c2
pawn just Queen captures on d4 it would
be would be really funny but of course
that didn't happen if Queen captures
rook captures on c2 is checkmate
there's nowhere to go b1 is covered by
the knight and the rook well controlled
the error squares but okay here it goes
Knight d2 now they're adding a defender
to the c3 Knight and here rook the c5
chunk is now ready to double up rooks
and the C file and continue the attack
against the nearest King
with Queen to d4 giri offers a queen
trade and now a five Chung says okay
we'll trade but I want to trade by
capturing with a capture son v4 and here
Gary repeats should not repeats but he
plays King to be to now this night can
move there's another defender here but
probably or me just maybe he's offering
a draw here by Knight to c4 King a1 and
just a repetition here but hyung is not
interested in the draw he pushes the
White Queen back with rook the c4
attacking the Queen and now Queen back
to d3 and here rook F to c8 bringing the
other rook into the attack as well and
here Gary had a very nice well a very
nice idea he could have gone queen to h3
it so it's a very nice plan involves a
rook sacrifice to kind of force a draw
for example black continues attacking on
the Queen side like white has no threat
giri could force a draw with rook
captures on f17 captures and the Queen
to e6 check King to g7 and now Queen to
e7 check will force black to repeat
moves you have to go up the board
because if you go to King gauge 6 then
Queen will capture on f6 and here Gary
is better because the knight on c3 is
defended by the Queen but it's a tough
line to find you know in a rapid game so
here I played rook the c1 instead here
that another defender to the c2 pawn and
she um continued attacking on the Queen
side with b5 and now again
Queen to h3 still an idea with with the
same little trick and for example if a
black decides the trade rooks then just
captures captures and there is no threat
here on c3 you can just continue your
your play on the King side but here Gary
played f5 and here it will it's just bad
for Geary so feel free to fire to pause
the video and try to find the winning
idea for Geoffrey in this position while
I give you a couple of seconds so for
those who were able to do it
congratulations and finding such a nice
tactic in such a short time and for
those who just want to enjoy the show
the idea is rook captures on c3 the
point is that now of course gear
captured once but then after rook
captures on c3 you cannot capture again
because if you capture nicéphore check
and now you have to move the king and
you lose the Queen since the pawn is
pinned or if you don't want to give up
the Queen for nothing you're just gonna
capture here and then just be captured
on c4 you're down a queen that's of
course reasonable so after rook captures
on c3 Queen e2 was played by giri and
now comes Knight to c4 check with into
a1 and now Knight back to a 5 not
allowing any tricks for Geary and just
closing up that file for the Queen
with F captors and g 6h characters on g6
and now look to f1 giri brings the more
attackers to the king side but now Queen
to d4 threatening a lot of nasty
discoveries here once the rook moves so
king b1 preventing all the nastiness and
enough comes Knight captures on d5 so
what do you do here you there are no
threats on the f7 points since the
knight is guarded the Knight is guarding
the f7 pony you cannot give up the Queen
for this rook captures on f7 check as
the black King will escape there is no
continuation here so giri played rook to
d1 attacking the Queen so black is
unable to capture on e7 but here
Geoffrey finds just a beautiful
defensive maneuver well sort of an
attacking maneuver rook to d3 freeing
the c3 square for the knight and now
Knight to c3 trick will pick up the
Queen that is the threat for example if
you capture Knight c3 check pics of the
Queen and it's all over
so Gary had to capture with the rook he
played rook captures on d3 with Knight
captures on d3 again the idea is the
same if you capture a knight c3 check
just wins the Queen
so Queen captures on d3 was played and
after Queen captures you see that well
once the Queen is captured the knight
will pick up the rook and that well soon
we'll just be up a piece so here we just
captured on f7 sort of to make to make
the game last longer or something we
have King captures on f7 and now C
captures on d3
after Knight to a4 it was in this
position that onigiri resigned the game
as he is down a whole piece and there is
no compensation here so real really
really a tough match and Giri also had a
tough match before this he took it all
the way to Armageddon and he was able to
emerge victorious in Armageddon but here
uh.well around before going into the
blitz games Jefferies young emerges
victorious in the rapid section so Giri
is out of the feeder World Cup and
Jeffrey's young continues at around 4
and so we don't forget to let's just
check out who faces who in the next
round tomorrow so here it is also from
the chess 24 website the top seeding
Liron faces Kido Alok Cinco the 22-year
old Russian Grand Master who is just the
surprise of the World Cup basically as
he is the only player who lasted this
long who is rated below 2,700 so all the
other players are pretty much 2700 plus
elites and in the previous round he
eliminated well in this round basically
a Penta a Hari Krishna which is just an
amazing achievement
so ding will face off against Alex Cinco
then we have linear Domingues will face
Alexander Greece shook gonna be a really
awesome awesome match then we have
Westley stall vs Nikita a tube of V to
have eliminated Sergey kurakin after a
Carrigan's terrible blunder in in the
last game they played but you know yeah
what are you gonna do
Janna pony she will face you yongi also
gonna be a very awesome match and the
Jeffress young who won this match
against and here it will face young
shift of Duda also definitely a match to
be promoted so we're gonna have a lot of
fun tomorrow
Sharma media will face team or a job of
an all-out Azerbaijan brawl and we have
a mock scene for sure holograph who also
had to take his match against the
demetria kvitko into the into the blade
section and then he was able to win into
the blade section of the match Peter
Svidler eliminated me soprano was a
again a very tough match but so whittler
emerged victorious so it will be really
a clash of titans wheeler versus Maxime
and we have 11 Ireland versus eloquently
11 eliminated the Maxie Matlock of
whereas eloquently and eliminated the
very strong what's the name forgot it's
gonna come back to me sorry about that
nope I'm gonna have to check but but you
can check for yourself so really sorry
about that blockade seems to have
occurred but yeah that's that's the game
I do hope you enjoyed it and to explain
the port above the board Magnus said
this I've lost my will to live after
onigiri was eliminated from the feeder
World Cup stating how incredibly sad he
is that a giri is leaving the defeated
World Cup but yeah I do hope you enjoyed
it I would like to thank Alex lahrman
and piata Rihanna for a contribution to
my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here I think all
for watching and I will see you soon
I'll continuing the coverage of the
feeder World Cup checking up on your
suggestions and you know whatever else
interesting happens in the chess world
so thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day